hi my name is Jimmy Wang I'm the
director of culinary innovation for
Panda Express here's how we're gonna
make the original orange chicken at home
start with fried chicken we feel like
when you cut the thigh meat into about a
one-inch cube I kind of gives you the
best texture out of every bite and also
retains the best moisture so we wanted
to use the dark meat to help to sort of
keep that moisture in there while the
outside is crispy the inside is nice and
tender and juicy so using the wet batter
to coat the chicken it gives a little
bit of aeration to the crust and it also
coats the chicken better so the batter
itself has a leavening agent such as an
egg and we also use cornstarch plus AP
flour to help to have some sort of a
crust with the wheat and then also a
little bit of starch so that there's a
crunch
Alpana Express is the originator of
orange chicken the story goes back to 87
chef Andy cow was working with local
chicken he was testing couple different
badges people smelled it so the customer
was just automatic says I want that
instead founder and chairman andrew saw
the whole thing he was like this might
be it
we actually want to fry the chicken in
badges at 350 degrees it's roughly about
25 pieces at a time so that way the
pockets would get overcrowded we want to
fry at least six minutes one of the
things that we'll also need to remind
people is that the shade of the color
that you fry in here by the time you
take it out and rest it's gonna go one
shade darker so we always want to go a
little bit lighter when people think of
fast food they think is processed with
Chinese food there is no way to cheat it
they always have to do it exactly the
way that is or else it doesn't come up
with the riving salt everything is very
technical that's one thing that we're
really proud of
I think orange juice definitely give the
assimilate as needed the vinegar have to
be the potency in it so you want it to
the nose if you boil it earlier the
vinegar comes off then you don't get it
so that's why you can always smell the
orange chicken when you go to the stores
because that vinegar really hits
so we're looking for almost like maple
syrup consistency when the chicken is
nice and ha when you drop it into the
sauce there's gonna absorb by the way so
it could be a little bit wetter the
sesame oil to gives extra Sheen and also
a toast that nuttiness to the dish one
of the reason why I think it becomes a
giant dish there's a certain estava
about a taste of sweet and sour think
about ketchup post slaw barbecue sauce
when you think about a sweet and sour
flavor
combined with sort of something very
iconic as fried chicken that really
really hits home really good
you